alors que peuvent elles donner ces
monnaies locales et bien on va en parler
tout de suite dans ce débat et on attend
bien sûr vos réactions sur le hashtag
docu débat alors ce documentaire devise
citoyenne monnaies locales on vous le
dois gérons de florenville merci d'être
avec nous près de vous et olivier pastré
bonjour vous êtes économiste professeur
à paris 8
en face de vous jean françois rousseau
bienvenue vous êtes économiste également
chercheur sur les thématiques monétaire
et enfin jean philippe magnen bonjour
bonjour vous êtes vice président de la
région pays de loire d'europe écologie
les verts auteur d'un rapport sur les
monnaies locales remis à la secrétaire
d'état au commerce carole delga en 2015
bienvenue à tous alors gérant de
florenville pourquoi vous vous êtes
intéressé à ce sujet les monnaies
locales ma part comme une initiative
citoyenne intéressante assez méconnu
peut encore médiatisé fallait commencer
ce travail il ya un peu plus d'un an ça
commence à prendre un petit peu plus
d'ampleur aujourd'hui ça me paraissait
un petit peu méconnu et puis porter de
de pas mal de promesses alors j'ai
commencé à rassembler ce qui pouvait
exister dans la presse puis on a appelé
ça ça ça me hante ou un an j'ai passé
plusieurs mois
aller à la rencontre de ces monnaies
voir ce qui se passait danse beaucoup de
choses très très différentes
ça peut se passer au niveau de d'une
ville d'une petite ville des projets sur
des quartiers mais qui compte encore
abouti et puis jusqu'à le choc ok sur
tout
toute une région ça prend des formes
très très diverses avec toujours cette
idée de à travers la monnaie favoriser
l'écologie favoriser les circuits courts
et favoriser les les rapports humains
fluidifier tout ça ça peut ça peut
apporter pas mal de changements positifs
dans la société c'est ce qui m'a parlé
au début et finalement c'est un
phénomène qui est assez peu connu
pourquoi déjà c'est assez nouveau face à
en france ça a paru qu'en 2010 ça me 5
mis du temps à s'installer et puis après
au début ça c'est peut-être un petit peu
difficile à appréhender parce que je
sens ça prend plusieurs formes
donc les gens sont un petit peu
timide quand je dis les gens les
politiques ont une appréhension sont
assez distant encore par rapport à celle
j'allais vous dire vous avez sollicité
des intervenants politiques pour être
documentaire oui et alors tout est
globalement je sais pas j'ai
l'impression que ça aussi quand même
entre désintérêt voire limite du mépris
parfois il ya évidemment des politiques
qui se sont impliqués qui s'intéressent
des gens qui font des choses mais
globalement il ya beaucoup de méfiance
est en fait beaucoup d'incompréhension
j'ai l'impression que les politiques
prennent ça pour quelque chose
d'extrêmement alternatifs alors qu'on
parle pas enfin pour moi c'est pas des
monnaies alternatives qui ont pour but
de remplacer leurs au travail tardif et
complémenter complémentaire c'est pour
venir en plus pour faire autre chose
mais pour emmener r ça on va on va y
revenir au long du débat alors
effectivement on constate dans le
documentaire que autour d'un même projet
une monnaie alors quelle que soit la
région
les personnalités les sensibilités les
motifs sont très différents donc c'est
un sujet qui fédère
pourquoi selon vous parce qu'il ya un
besoin
il ya un besoin de retrouver du sens à
la monnaie il ya un besoin de vivre
ensemble et puis après un besoin
économique ça si ça peut aider au
développement de l'écologie si ça peut
aider à recentrer le les centre-villes
fin à redynamiser l'économie dans des
centres villes dans des petites villes
dans des petits villages fait tout ça
c'est des choses très différentes ça
touche des acteurs très différents
et puis à la fin on voit qu'il ya des
gens qui sont retraités qui font partie
de ces mouvements des gens qui sont
étudiants des gens qui sont actifs des
gens qui sont très politisés et d'autres
pas et puis d'ailleurs on voit dans les
associations des gens qui peuvent être
de droite de gauche façon c'est
indifférenciée alors que les politiques
sont assez frileux et puis globalement
c'est plutôt les verts et les
socialistes qui porte sa mais dans les
gens qui sont acteurs qui sont moteurs
de toutes ces monnaies c'est assez
neutre je tairai globalement les centres
qu'est-ce qui esquisse qui ressort pour
réaction à ce documentaire et magnin ils
illustrent assez parfaitement ce qu'on a
pu constater lors de la mission que j'ai
conduite avec christophe fourel terre
qui a une émergence d'un mouvement très
territorial
deux personnes qui disent aujourd'hui en
gros les deux messages c'est ça suffit
on n'a plus du tout de vision claire de
ce qu'est la monnaie et comment elle
peut être équilibré dans ses fonctions
parce que faut le rappeler c'est les
fonctions de la monnaie c'est avant tout
l'intermédiation des échanges et
qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des échanges
monétaires sont uniquement sur ce qu'on
appelle la réserve de la valeur c'est à
dire de la vocation spéculatif derrière
et que dans les échanges mondiaux
aujourd'hui la plupart des échanges sur
le marché des changes chaque jour
concerne le marché spéculatif et non pas
l'économie réelle et les gens disent
ras-le-bol on a envie de se réapproprier
ces échanges directs
effectivement en circuit court donc ça
il ya une catégorie très militante
et puis il ya des gens très pragmatique
c'est les petites et moyennes
entreprises qui disent aujourd'hui on ne
se sent plus concerné y compris par
l'économie parce que y compris le monde
bancaire ne nous accorde plus de crédit
pour développer notre activité et ses
défauts la nous permettent pas de
développer notre activité donc on va
créer une propre organisation inter
relationnel entre les entreprises d'un
même territoire
avec ce qu'ils appellent des chambres de
compensation pour permettre justement de
se faire crédit et de développer
l'activité économique plus directement
donc voilà il ya une dynamique qui à la
fois citoyen très politique et puis très
pragmatique du côté des entreprises de
dire on se réapproprie gens font ça pour
ça c'est exactement ça d'ailleurs c'est
ce qu'on voit très bien dans le film
c'est l'initiative très souvent elle est
citoyenne et ses citoyens qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent ils veulent en fait se
réapproprier la monnaie parce que il se
trouve que depuis quelques années
effectivement certains citoyens
considèrent que la monnaie ne sert plus
à financer l'économie réelle la monnaie
spéculatives comme ça a été dit certains
d'autres vins d'autres personnes
considèrent que la monnaie c'est c'est
la monnaie des banquiers et on sait tous
ce qui s'est passé avec les banques ces
dernières années donc l'idée c'est de se
réapproprier la monnaie est de se donner
comment dire des marges de manoeuvre au
niveau local pour se fixer des objectifs
à ses contemporains finalement 1
comment promouvoir l'écologie le
développement local limité
l'exclusion de certaines personnes à
l'échelle locale
tout ça à travers les monnaies locales
olivier pastré vous votre regard et je
sais qu'il est différent sur les
monnaies locales quand vous entendez 7e
mais non ça vachement bien juste deux
remarques par rapport à votre
intervention liminaire 1 c'est
absolument pas nouveau ce soir mon temps
ou au pire au pire ou moyenne
deuxièmement alternatif oui mais c'est
déjà ça y'a pas il n'y a pas quatre ans
il ya toujours en période de crise une
remontée des monnaies locales donc la
crise disons que ça a commencé au 19e
siècle et crise tels qu'on les connaît
aujourd'hui donc c'est pas nouveau
deuxièmement alternative c'est même pas
en rêve complémentaires oui alternatifs
non géré on a besoin de l'euro demeure
du père natif systématique c'est l'un ou
l'autre ou juristes et relative comme le
courant c'est on allume ont éteint on
est bien ça va pas éteindre les échanges
citi sont pas forcément qu'ils sont pas
forcément tous spéculatifs qui lie à un
vrai point et c'est le charme de ces
émissions on a un peu le temps de parler
c'est de lier ça à des phénomènes
actuels qui redonne aux monnaies
alternatives tout en apportant 6 à 1
le bitcoin que comme un sujet qui
intéresse tout le monde y compris les
banques centrales de la drachme qui est
une les locales qui va devenir une
monnaie locale
je pense que et le ce qui se passe en
grèce et le bitcoin redonne un intérêt à
comment sortir du système tel qu'il est
bouclé aujourd'hui et qui n'est pas sans
sans faille un jeu je défends pas
l'orthodoxie monétaire dis simplement
que c'est pas alternatif c'est
complémentaire
c'est en général ou assez généralement
en période de crise
et par dire est par construction au
niveau local et donc dessiné à le rester
et animale
jean-philippe derrière vous vous dites
que la question des monnaies locales et
plus en plus en plus par an prise en
compte par les élus notamment lors des
dernières municipales ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que il ya une poussée
citoyenne qui incite à prendre en compte
sa pose la question de la démocratie
c'est à dire que les élus sont très
attentifs à la démocratie politique
c'est à dire à un moment donné une
expression citoyenne par rapport à vivre
ensemble sur un territoire donné quelle
que soit l'échelle territoriale et puis
à ce qu'on appelle la démocratie
économique
on vient d'en parler c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un vrai problème
d'accès à l'économie pour un certain
nombre de catégories de population deux
catégories d'entreprises et donc se
rapproche sur les territoires à la fois
des tenants de la démocratie politique
de dire on se réapproprie en tant que
citoyen le sens de la monnaie et donc de
les changes
et puis à des entreprises qui disent à
un moment donné il faut de nouvelles
économies parce que l'économie dominante
qu'on nous propose aujourd'hui elle ne
répond plus elle ne répond plus à un
développement d'activités qui supprime
les intermédiaires qui fait en sorte que
le producteur soit proche du
consommateur etc etc alors ça remplace
pas les échanges mondiaux
c'est effectivement complémentaire du
système officiel sauf que quand même si
le système officiel parce que ce qui se
passe en grèce aujourd'hui le problème
qu'il ya c'est que on peut aussi avoir
une deuxième crise après celle de 2008
on peut avoir une crise encore plus
grave les économistes le disent alors je
pas ce que vous en pensez messieurs mais
les économistes disent on n'est pas à
l'abri d'une nouvelle crise monétaire et
ce qui s'est passé en argentine au début
des années 2000 avec le truc qui est
devenu une monnaie alternative alors que
le projet de départ était une monnaie
complémentaire
donc là il ya vraiment une question
fondamentale de dire est ce que le
système monétaire officielle centrale
est aujourd'hui durable et c'est pas
dire est ce que les monnaies
complémentaires le son c'est quel
système monétaire pluriel aujourd'hui
pour maintenir les échanges sur le sur
le plan planétaire mais aussi donc sur
nos territoires
une réaction je suis d'accord avec l'ec
l'exemple argentin c'est l'exemple
typique on s'aperçoit que dans toute
société
on a besoin d'une monnaie on était au
coeur de la crise argentine la monnaie
ne remplissait plus son rôle et les
terres rares
il avait un
système monétaire assez contestable et
donc évidemment il ya des monnaies qui
spontanément son nez ce qui montre qu'on
a toujours besoin de la monnaie ça c'est
quelque chose qui est nécessaire en
revanche soulager un petit point de
désaccord c'est sur le côté
centralisateur eux c'était en argentine
si ces monnaies sont développées c'est
pas parce qu'il y avait trop de
centralisation c'est parce que la
monnaie était en crise et leur faible
d'accord simplement lorsque la monnaie
est en crise
lorsque la monnaie n'incarne plus les
valeurs sacrées qu'il peut y avoir
autour de la monnaie
on voit apparaître spontanément des
monnaies alternatives
c'est ce qui se passe c'est pas par
hasard si c'est depuis 2008 1 qu' on a
un développement exceptionnel de ces
monnaies alors avançons alors pour
l'instant une trentaine de monnaies
locales sont en circulation en france le
phénomène reste assez marginale
et pourtant dans le monde ce sont 5000
monnaie locale qui circulent et qui
portent leurs fruits alors pourquoi ce
scepticisme français que peuvent nous
apporter éventuellement ces monnaies on
regarde un extrait de votre documentaire
ya eu quelques expériences à une
certaine époque lointain les grands
parents d'ici nous parle qu'il ya eu des
initiatives comme ça des moins bonnes et
alternatifs qui se sont trouvés
beaucoup de billets et pas du jour au
lendemain je passe c'était interdit ou
je sais pas c'est là le projet était
abandonné
bal à la monnaie avec une valeur donc
les anciens il nous parle de se méfier
donc il ya tout un travail de fond tout
un travail à mettre en place donc les
gens peut-être qu'ils sont pas
ils ont peur ou voilà c'est vrai que
s'il ya beaucoup plus de gens qui
sommeille en galets costa facilitera
beaucoup son fonctionnement oui alors
vous le disiez tout à l'heure des
monnaies locales en france il en a
toujours existé on peut remonter même
jusqu'au moyen-âge
il ya eu dans les années 50 les monnaies
dites franches il ya eu dans les années
90 les systèmes d'échangés locaux
qu'est ce qui a échoué finalement
pourquoi ces monnaies elles n'ont jamais
perdu en jambes sont là je crois qu'on
était dans des circonstances très
différentes
on était dans un sens dans un système
peut-être plus centralisée qui
fonctionnait à l'époque
aujourd'hui on voit que le système
centralisé est en crise et puis on était
aussi dans un contexte moins globalisé
sur le plan financier
ce que contestent les les adeptes des
monnaie locale complémentaire c'est le
monde d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire ils
contestent les excès de la finance le
fait que la globalisation financière a
pris le pas sur l'économie réelle
le fait que aujourd'hui les activités
économiques exploite l'humain exploitent
les ressources naturelles
à l'époque on n'avait pas encore ça et à
mon avis c'est peut-être ça qui
expliquent elles se sont pas développés
à l'époque où l'on doit à quoi est-ce
que nos mendy vais pas stressé et 2008
le krach boursier
la crise les monnaies locales son fils
de la crise ça veut pas dire qu'il n'y a
pas de monnaie locale qui se développe
en dehors des périodes de crise met
enfin en gros c'est quand même tous les
peuples à la crise est ce que ça traduit
aussi un malaise socio économique oui
mais comme plein de choses comme quand
on sortira de ce plateau
le chauffeur de taxi sera de mauvaise
humeur parce qu'ils aient eu bel air oui
enfin baisser c'est un tout moi ce qui
me choque c'est kobe c'est qu'on
présente ça comme une alternative
et comme le produit de la crds il ya une
crise je me découvre dans ce débat
trotskiste qui est quand même un scoop
c'est à dire que moi je suis rentré dans
le système et le déstabiliser mais je
rentre dans le système je ne dis pas je
fais quelque chose en dehors
moi je pense qu'il faut réformer la
finance elle ne marche pas il faut
financer vous parliez de financement des
pme mais je crois pas que le menu
alternatif montre que marginalement
permet de financement des pme il ya un
vrai problème du système bancaire en
france qui financent pas les pme
traitons ce sujet là après moi je trouve
ça très bien mais par nature parlons-en
qu'est ce qui marche ou pas est-ce que
derrière ça c'est une critique de l'euro
par exemple
qu'est ce qui ne convient pas
aujourd'hui aux citoyens pour développer
sa au delà de la crise là il faut six
heures et demie ah oui mais
objectivement le système convient de
l'économie n'ont rien oui c'est qu'on
fait tout pour que le site one
comprennent plus efficace mais je suis
totalement d'accord alors que l'outil
monétaire devrait servir à l'échangé de
biens de services et sur des territoires
quels qu'ils soient je vais évoquer un
autre phénomène qui est exactement la
même chose qui est le développement du
troc
moi je suis un camarade le pas la chance
d'être dans l'ouest il fait chaud il
fait plus chaud qu'à marne en ce moment
le en camargue il y à un développement
exponentiel du troc
parce que le système des changes
monétaires centralisée a des
inconvénients
moi je suis pour le réformer pour qu'il
y ait moins d'inconvénients il ya des
gens qui prennent un choix alternatif et
il ya des jeux ankama qui vivent à 99%
par le troc ce qui est une autre façon
de contourner un système monétaire qui
fonctionne moyennement bien dirigés oui
parce que je pense que le système des
monnaies locales complémentaires et pas
un système alternatif
il est d'ailleurs elles sont à parité de
l'euro donc ya pas de système
déstabilisant n'y a pas de création
monétaire en tant que tel dans une
monnaie complémentaire on ne crée pas de
la monnaie en plus c'est la même qui
circulent sauf qu'elle circule
différemment et plus vite parce que l'un
des aspects qu'on n'a pas évoqué c'est
qu'en période de crise la monnaie
officielle est ralentie ces mécaniques
presque donc elle est ralentie donc elle
circule encore moins vite qu'avant et
les monnaies complémentaires n'étant pas
soumis à cette ré écrit que la crise
monétaire et caen et en circuit court et
ne pouvant pas être théorisé donc ya pas
d épargne des monnaies complémentaires
et bâle circulent plus vite
cinq à sept fois plus vite que l'euro et
donc du coup sacré d'un système
d'échangé quand l'écosystème est prêt ça
ça influe sur les producteurs les
consommateurs et les citoyens et donc la
question de la consommation vous poser
la question pourquoi ça n'a pas marché à
l'époque je crois qu'il ya une prise de
conscience aussi des consommateurs
citoyens
aujourd'hui sur un certain nombre de
choses des produits agricoles comme vous
l'avez dit pour l'alimentation
l'alternative en matière énergétique il
ya un certain nombre de prises de
conscience qui font qu'aujourd'hui les
gens se disent je veux reprendre la main
sur ma consommation est ce que je
consomme et sa ramené à la question
monétaire et ben ça rapproche les
mouvements écolos pour moi reprendre
reprendre le contrôle sur sa
consommation 5e pas que mais en tout cas
c'est un des moyens pédagogiques de
redonner du sens à l'argent et les
chances et on est un marché avec des
chartes avec des règles les commerçants
les petites entreprises où d'ailleurs
certaines entreprises de taille c'est
important qui fonctionne qui a bercé à
ces monnaies locales ont signé une
charte dans cette chartre il y à
s'occuper de retraiter ses déchets
correctement il ya s'occuper d'avoir
dans son entreprise un certain respect
de ses collaborateurs ça c'est une autre
façon de fonctionner en interne et aussi
en externe ya faire attention quand
c'est possible travailler avec des gens
qui sont à proximité et pas aller
chercher plus loin trop loin faire
circuler dès que des cadavres
c'est plus écologique plus économique ça
il ya toute cette ferme de valeur qui
redonne du sens c'est quand même ça
c'est une notion importante et est alors
vous parlez des écosystèmes concernés
les monnaies locales en france sont
particulièrement présentes dans l'ouest
et le sud et les territoires fortement
impacté par la crise pourquoi uniquement
c'est aussi très présent dans les
grandes villes dynamiques comme toulouse
nantes bientôt à grenoble et un projet
de monnaies locales à grenoble qui se
développe actuellement
bon c'est quand même ça fait témoigne
d'une dynamique qui effectivement
correspond à une catégorie population
c'est-à-dire des populations qui vit
plutôt dans des villes des villes assez
grande un des villes où on a
effectivement une conception plus
écologique des choses une dimension
vivre environnementales plus présent
tant dans la façon de consommer par
exemple à grenoble la ville d'où je
viens le projet actuel il vise à relier
re localiser les
des activités économiques c'est à dire
consommer localement promouvoir les
circuits courts
par exemple j'ai souvenir d'un
restaurateur qui disait que lui ce qui
l'intéressait dans la monnaie locale à
grenoble c'était éventuellement signer
la charte des valeurs de cette monnaie
locale
c'était d'acheter ses tomates à moins de
30 kilomètres de grenoble
plutôt que de les acheter en provenance
de hollande
donc on voit bien que l'objectif ici
c'est transformé également les
comportements et je crois que c'est à
travers ces monnaies locales on n'a pas
qu'une vision alternative radicale
il ya aussi une conception très
contemporaine qui se tient pas
responsable si oui si les cours rehaussé
de sa bulle et des logiques c'est un
outil pédagogique aussi c'est pâques un
outil économique
ça sert à faire prendre conscience aux
gens de ces problématiques écologiques
c'est vraiment un outil ça peut être ça
peut être un outil pour aller pour aller
vers autre chose olivier pastré voulait
rage
oui oui moi moi je suis le méchant
puisque je suis ni non non dit non mais
attends les jeux ça se voit déjà la
seule chose le seul bémol et je pense
qu'on peut se mettre d'accord on peut se
mettre d'accord sur le fait que c'est
plutôt une initiative c'est positif dans
un monde hyper centralisé recréer de la
décentralisation
on sent tous que c'est comme ça que la
sortie de crise va se faire et c'est
tant mieux donc là-dessus premier point
deuxième point il faudrait pas que les
gens qui l'utilisent crois que c'est
plus qu'une monnaie locale
je vais faire un parallèle qui va vous
choquer peut-être êtes historien à mener
donc
ça va ça va avoir des relais les
répercussions dans votre réflexion
mais quelque part ça ressemble un peu
aux marchés dérivés
c'est à dire des membres est sûr du
résultat c'est à dire ceux qui sont à
l'origine de la crise et qui sont des
marchés non centraliser davantage la
monnaie c'est que on utilise l'état et
éventuellement la banque centrale puis
de plus en plus la banque centrale pour
créer la confiance à l'échelle d'un
territoire
on le voit en grèce en ce moment est
d'ailleurs partout en europe
est ce que j'ai dit un quart de seconde
que ça marchait par tous deux
partenaires mais la pensée non mais en
tout cas c'est là la philosophie les
marchés dérivés comme certaines monnaies
locales
c'est on n'a pas besoin d'un état on va
échanger entre nous
d'où mon parlait avec le troc quelque
part si les gens sont conscients du
caractère local
pardon mais marginal ça changera
peut-être mais aujourd'hui c'est
relativement marginal ça va très bien si
on donne l'impression que c'est une
monnaie dont parallèle avec bitcoins
étude menée en veille au sens général il
ya des risques voilà c'est tout juste
moins un point là dessus parce que ce
qui se passe ailleurs qu'en france
notamment en angleterre
ouais à l'impasse sur la ville de
bristol par exemple va à l'encontre de
ce qui vient d'être dit c'est à dire
c'est pas seulement qu'un projet
sympathique appartements des
collectivités locales sont en passe
la législation permet par exemple de
payer les services publics locaux la
cantine le centre socioculturel la
piscine en monnaie locale et que 10% de
la population comme c'est le cas à
bristol dans une ville de quatre cent
soixante sept mille habitants utilisent
la monnaie locale quelle police
allemande
là ça a un impact et en plus ils payent
leur taquet avec ce qui est plus qui est
pas possible j'en sais ce qui est sain
on en reparle accord mais si vous êtes
une grosse entreprise à bristol
vous allez quand même vous servez servir
de mener centraliser une histoire mais
on y reviendra
olivier pastré joie il revient on entend
autour de ces monnaies les mots de
solidarité
la dimension sociale qui reviennent est
ce que ces monnaies ont vocation à
diriger vers jugement l'entrepreneuriat
social
aujourd'hui on a le ministère d'économie
sociale et solidaire est ce que ce sont
des signaux aussi envoyé d'en haut
pour repenser d'une certaine façon est
donnée d utilisation comment il faut
interpréter aujourd'hui
l'entrepreneuriat social est intacte
dans lequel on met énormément de choses
dont on met tout et n'importe quoi c'est
le concept le plus creux en termes
d'années les économies que j'aie jamais
rencontré de ma vie rien donc voilà le
truc y est par ailleurs je finis après
je me laisse critiquer par ailleurs les
impulsions décentralisatrice commandé
par le haut j'y crois pas vraiment je
voulais faire un parallèle et qui a tout
à tous tout son sens
me semble-t-il par rapport aux monnaies
locales qui est le mutualisme en général
et la coopération
les deux mouvements monnaies locales et
coopérations sont pas sans relation et
la preuve c'est qu'au 19e siècle quand
s'est lancé le mouvement coopératif et
mutualiste
il ya eu des essais de monnaies locales
et je réponds à la question il est clair
que un des points essentiels s'il ya
plus de centralisation
il faut de la solidarité et de ce point
de vue là les monnaies locales sont le
témoin d'une solidarité qui est proche
de la philosophie mutualistes et
coopératives
je me demande pourquoi les mutuelles et
les groupes coopératifs ne se sert pas
plus de monnaies locales ici intéresse
ici intéresse mais sont pas obsédés
notamment les banques mutualistes et
coopératives qui pense plus à créer des
holdings financières qu'elle a respecté
les valeurs de base et historique oui
mais ça comment que je m'aime bien
développement de certaines banques
coopératives qui s'intéresse de près ces
expériences de monnaies locales et je
crois que ça c'est quelque chose qui est
très nouveau
bon en même temps faut savoir une chose
c'est que ces monnaies locales se sont
pas des monnaies au sens monnaie
bancaire dans le sens où il n'ya pas
comment dire derrière une logique de
crédit c'est à dire comme cela a été
souligné tout à l'heure on a de l'euro
on le convertit en monnaies locales et
cette monnaie c'est comme si à changer
de couleur en quelque sorte
et avec cette monnaie là on fait autre
chose alors que dans les monnaies
bancaire il ya quelque chose d'assez
magique qu olivier pastré connais bien
ce qui est la création monétaire
cela dit on peut créer de la monnaie à
partir de rien dans les monnaies locales
pour l'instant il n'y a pas ça et c'est
un signe que effectivement le
déploiement peut se faire de façon que
ralentie que
développement de la monnaie bancaire
mais en même temps il ya une sorte de
sécurité en quelque sorte
y'a pas des risques excessives qui sont
pris comme par les banques alors sont
concrètement sur ces monnaies la plus
active en france et le sco au pays
basque avec 350 milles équivalent en
euros pourquoi celle-ci fonctionne mieux
que d'autres en algérie monétaire
derrière les monnaies locales au même
titre que tout autre politique monétaire
je trouve que dans le cas de la monnaie
bas ce qui est quelque chose de très
particulier c'est la dimension
identitaire voire communautaire et là il
ya quelque chose de très intéressant
parce que de tous temps les monnaies
renvoie à une communauté à des valeurs
partagées par les utilisateurs de cette
monnaie alors dans le cabas ce que
certains diront oui peut-être que ça va
loin et la promotion de la langue basque
la culture basque certains contextes on
voit sur le terrain le le sais c'est pas
le facteur forcément le plus en avant
mais comme ça compte beaucoup le fait
que cette monnaie est de la promotion de
la langue basque fait sa première longue
donne une bonne image et fédérateur
vraiment fortement enfin et puis on voit
dans le film pareil cette histoire de
charte quand on a une petite boutique
etc ont adhéré à le ch kof ou un
restaurant m'ont fait sa carte en
français et puis en basque les beaucoup
d'enfants vont apprendre le basque puis
les plus anciens par le basque ça fait
ça fait un peu le lien entre les
générations se peut dire il ya un trou
mais on revient solidarité je pense que
s'ils ont des identités des territoires
en fait oui enfin l'identité tant la
forme suprême de la solidarité bouger
mais s'est demandé dans le même domaine
et il faut mais attendez la monnaie
c'est la confiance c'est pas moi qui ai
inventé ça je dire donc gir 6 a pas de
confiance il ya pas de monnaie qu'elle
soit locale ou mondiale
la confiance elle secret au niveau local
a fortiori quand il ya des combats
dianté je connais pas la cartographie
c'est pas mon domaine de spécialité
la cartographie des monnaies locales
dans le monde je crois qu'elle avait
2500 le décanat 5000
je pense que ça se trouve dans des
territoires qui sont très identitaire
vous parlez du sud
je constate le cidre le sudes à part le
vaucluse où il ya la ronde mais moi il y
en a très peu
parce que c'est une région qui a été
malgré tout frédéric mistral assez
largement imploser dans son identité
le pays basque le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que c'est pas imploser ils
sont
rires ça fait partie de l'identité
basque et je pense que pour beaucoup de
mener il ya une dimension identitaire
qui est très forte et tant mieux d'être
de magna cette dimension est importante
et en même temps c'est pas la seule
parce que sinon il y aurait des monnaies
lui-même arrivé en bretagne en corse
mairie et ce n'est pas le cas tériade il
ya une monnaie en bretagne par le gall
et comme est plus dans une impulsion de
la collectivité locale en l'occurrence
le conseil départemental et l'impulsion
citoyenne du pays basque elle s'est mêlé
aussi à une histoire de ce territoire
sur les finances solidaires ou
alternatives
la convention par exemple entre la
monnaie aux co et la société de capital
risque solidaire herrikoa c'est une
première en france c'est à dire que les
euros que vous déposez au bureau de
change
ils sont réinvestis dans du financement
solidaire sur l'économie locale
et là on pourrait se dire il ya un peu
de création monétaire puisque il n'ya
pas cantonnement de la monnaie dans un
fonds de réserve mais la monnaire
circulent quand l'euro est déposé dans
la banque et la monnaie locale circule
aussi dans sa communauté des changes et
en pays basque c'est quand même une
première il ya cette société de capital
est solidaire qui utilisent les euros
qui ont été déposés par ceux qui ont
pris des au sco et c'est un début de
modèle qui va plus loin parce que dans
l'histoire cette société de capital
risque existe depuis des décennies et
donc c'est une culture locale plus que
seulement identitaire je crois jean
françois rousseau je reviens à cette
idée de d'ingénierie monétaire qu'est ce
qu'il faut il faut la confiance le
fameux choix papier ou monnaie de compte
il faut en fait on s'aperçoit que c'est
assez technique
pourquoi au moins que ça fonctionne dans
l'environnement dans lequel ça
fonctionne oui pour que ça fonctionne il
ya plusieurs conditions qui doivent être
réunies moi je dirais qu'il y en a au
moins deux ou trois la première c'est il
faut inventer un mécanisme qui soit
relativement simples avec des objectifs
bien identifier très clair
parce que sinon comment on peut attirer
d'autres d'autres citoyens d'autres
utilisateurs
si la personne qui m'avait deuxième
élément il faut qu'il ya un écosystème
local c'est à dire il faut que les
acteurs qui s'impliquent là dedans il
suffit pas qu'ils aient des citoyens
parce que sinon effectivement il faut
aussi qu'ils aient des prestataires des
entreprises qui viennent s'appliquer là
dedans sinon qu'est-ce qu'on va échanger
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
pas grand chose est-ce qu'il faut un
financement à la base et justement le
troisième acteur qui est essentiel ce
sont les collectivités locales on voit
ça à travers le film le soutien
financier au départ le soutien également
dans le cadre d'une politique plus
générale dans le cadre de l'économie
sociale et solidaire ça coûte combien il
était locale bas ça dépend des endroits
mais des endroits ça coûtait très bon
moi je viens de grenoble il ya une
expérience malheureuse chez nous à
grenoble qui a coûté à un petit peu cher
mais justement ça a échoué parce que le
dispositif était trop compliqué parce
que il y avait des objectifs n'étaient
pas toujours très bien identifiés mais
surtout parce qu'il n'y avait pas à ces
prestataires passé de que d'entreprises
qui jouaient le jeu mais il faut
également les collectivités locales ça
c'est important ça peut pas venir d'en
haut parce que sinon on retourne dans
une logique effectivement c'est un
pouvoir politique qui qui est qui met en
place un schéma monétaire mais en même
temps il faut qu'ils aient soutien sinon
au départ en tout cas mais pas pourquoi
voulez vous écoute il ya l'exemple s'est
dit dans le film le gall échos
subventionné pour un petit peu moins de
cent mille euros par an mais la question
c'est qu'est ce qu'on à quoi ça sert ccc
cent mille euros ça serve ce sera
justement encore une fois à beaucoup de
choses
c'est pas il ya deux salariés qui
travaillent à mettre en réseau des
petits commerces et la problématique
n'est pas la même ce que ça marche sur
trois villes à rennes et à redon et à
fougères pour la petite ville de redon
face à créer un système qui effaça aide
à ce que le commerce reste vivant dans
une petite ville où vraiment les des
rideaux baissés et des magasins fermés y
en a il y en a beaucoup
à redon ça sert à consolider sa et puis
encore une fois en même temps c'est de
la pédagogie ça fait réfléchir à la fois
les commerçants et les particuliers
qu'est ce que je fais quand je consomme
quel sens ça et puis ça fait réfléchir à
l'écologie fait encore une fois c'est
vraiment
protéiforme ça fait beaucoup de choses
en même temps et je crois pas que ce
soit de l'argent
ficher en l'air quand on met son 1000
euros ça peut paraître beaucoup enfin ça
fait ça fait pas beaucoup de maîtres de
rue ou de face et pas tant que ça
l'échelle des dépenses est sacrée du ça
crée du lien social et à terme
encore une fois c'est de la pédagogie
alors parce qu'ils cherchent à un petit
point d'économies donc ces modèles sont
toutes différentes s'il ya des options
il ya dans le système convient d'évoquer
les options comme celui de la monnaie
fondante que vous abordez jérôme dans le
documentaire en gironde le miel est une
monnaie fondante
alors le principe en gros c'est qu'elles
perdent 2 centimes tous les six mois
c'est en fait le principe est assez
simple on s'est encouragé la circulation
la monnaie en lui faisant perdre de la
valeur
régulièrement donc on doit dépenser très
vite sinon on perd de l'argent
ce système est assez ancien qui était
autrichien que kane se trouvait très
ingénieux olivier pas pourquoi il a été
arrêté en autriche du jour au lendemain
et chez nous qu est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
va qu'est ce qui peut faire qu'est-ce
que quel sens il trouve c'est un bon
principe où il faudra qu'on parle du
bitcoin un moment ou un autre on y
arrive on y arrive mais j'allais dire
tout à l'heure parce que j'aille absolue
kane sort de ce corps de jeu je lis à
une dimension que vous évoquez dans dans
les monnaies locales qui est une
dimension très positive qui est de dire
il faut développer l'économie locale et
donc si on est solidaire on est
solidaires jusqu'au bout
donc ça limite ça ce type de monnaie à
des régions ou des zones dans lequel il
ya une production aussi à de la monnaie
pour acheter des produits locaux qui va
pas je pars don de faire le parallèle
avec la grèce mais c'est tellement
aveuglant que ça mérite d'être fait et
l'idée est de dire on va consommer
localement et donc consommant localement
on va encourager les producteurs locaux
kane sors de ce corps et donc ça va être
un moyen par l'augmentation de la
demande de créer de la valeur
ce qui est alors lancé je suis 100% pur
je dis simplement
il faut que ça reste le calme est pas
absurde dire qu'il faut qu'ils aient des
consommateurs et aussi des producteurs
locaux
il est une équation je sais pas si c'est
le cas en donne dans le pays basque je
pense que oui mais c'est pas un cas
général diable alors le bitcoin on y
vient il ya beaucoup de projets en
france qui ont été bloqués à cause du
bitcoin qui est un autre système qui est
totalement différente cela est ce que
vous pouvez qui veut nous expliquer les
différences avec les monnaies locales
dont on parle est ce qui fait peur à
travers le bitcoin aujourd'hui en france
olivier pastré ah mais c'est le
contraire avant le bitcoin c'est bête et
méchant
c'est là une création totalement ex
nihilo d'une monnaie mais après alors
versé spéculatifs anonyme ces apatrides
et pas c'est pas si l'objectif n'est pas
spéculatif la réalité c'est que c'est
spéculatifs c'est quelque chose qui est
totalement bits c'est l'unité compte
informatique école c est la pièce bon
c'est donc quelque chose qui a été créée
une manière totalement abstraite pour
faire des échanges et à mon avis au
début c'était presque un gimmick voir
quelque chose qui était fait pour le
le bordel dans la planète
financière jeu j'en sais rien je connais
on connaît pas quel est le créateur des
bitcoins il a un nom japonais
nakamoto de mémoire et c'est le
contraire parce que il ya aucune
solidarité il ya aucune centralisation
il ya des capacités de blanchiment
d'argent qui sont absolument infini ce
qui est la contradiction avec la monnaie
locale et il ya une volatilité qui est
totale et absolue c'est ça et le bitcoin
a perdu mini 1000 % de sa valeur en
quinze jours en 2014
bon voilà on est dans un univers alors
ça fait marrer les gogos
les banques centrales qui sont
extrêmement pudique veulent pas dire que
c'est quelque chose qui est quand même
très risqué puisque par ailleurs le
bitcoin ya une durée de vie limitée
je reviens à vos 90% l'idée c'est quand
même de d'accélérer le processus et de
faire des produits à durée limitée
tout ça est absolument terrifiant c'est
bête et méchant le bitcoin c'est
vraiment l'opposé de la monnaie locale
complémentaire
il n'y a pas de dimension sociale faut
aussi savoir que ceux qui ont créé le
bitcoin souvent été influencé par des
thèses on va dire libertarienne vraiment
pro marché pro concurrence alors que là
on est exactement l inverse c'est à dire
qu'on veut limiter les dérives ou les
excès de l'économie de marché l'économie
capitaliste alors que le bitcoin c'est
exactement l'inversé
alors qu'est ce qu'on redoute finalement
dans ces monnaies locales et les
finalement qu'est ce qu'on leur reproche
clairement pas déjà il ya l'état central
qui effectivement dans nos positions par
rapport à des monnaies locales parce que
normalement c'est l'état qui a le
monopole de l'émission de la monnaie
légale
là on a à l'échelle locale des monnaies
qui peuvent être émises
donc effectivement ça compte est en
quelque sorte le pouvoir souverain de
baht la monnaie
néanmoins ce qui est intéressant c'est
que la dernière loi de l'économie
sociale et solidaire à avancer sur ce
point là à travers l'article 16 et on a
légalisé en quelque sorte les monnaies
locales ça c'est une avancée quand même
très importante
et puis il ya un autre obstacle aussi à
ce développement c'est la confiance des
entreprises pour l'instant en france
seuls les tpe les artisans les
agriculteurs y croit alors qu'en suisse
en grande-bretagne au brésil et même au
japon allaient monnaies locales ont pris
leur place
une place particulière dans l'économie
depuis longtemps on réécoute un extrait
bon aujourd'hui des collectivités
locales sont coincés un petit plein
parce que demont et locale qu'elle
n'appelle d'être reconnus légalement par
la loi de juillet 2014 et tout est bio
et local quoi interroger
le trésor public localement pour savoir
si les collectivités pouvaient dit celui
des monnaies locales ou un acceptées en
paiement pour le ski en régie ou en
services municipaux ont idées reçues
donc on espère que c'est toi va faire
changer les choses
on a vraiment besoin de ça aujourd'hui
ça permettra de développer les eaux cile
monnaies locales et puis de permettre
aux collectivités locales de se saisir
de cet outil parce qu'on imagine d'une
subvention distribué en est ce qu on
dissimule à une association il se montre
en hausse qu elle peut utiliser que dans
les commerces du village ou des
alentours
donc ça fait vivre le commerce local ça
a un double impact je constate tout est
développée ça permet d'être pour une
mairie de dix tenues une subvention
quant à l'impact de soutien à
l'association de soutien culturel
allangba de soutien aux associations
locales de soutien au commerce local
dont il ya vraiment un intérêt fort où
les mérites en effet démultiplicateur
alors on l'a dit en france ce sont les
350 milles ce qu'au pays basque à qui
tiennent le haut du panier
c'est pas beaucoup et surtout ce n'est
rien à côté de la suisse par exemple
avec le vire qui pèse 2 % du pib
alors comment ça se fait c'est que cette
monnaie pèse ce poids là dans l'économie
suisse j'en profite déjà c'est un
dispositif qui est très ancien qui date
des années 30
on notera que ça a paru à peu près au
même moment que l'apparition du secret
bancaire
et puis tout simplement mal et perdure
il fonctionne l'économie suisse s'est
pas uniquement comme il fait même si le
sourire c'est ça c'est ça qui se sont
pas des pme qui sont spécialisés dans la
finance la suisse et pas que des banques
il ya aussi une industrie il ya une
agriculture très efficace des petites
entreprises
le veer a permis à ces entreprises de se
faire dès des crédits entre elle et ça
marche depuis de nombreuses décennies on
dit et passerait très normal de ça a été
évoqué tout à fait d'accord je crois pas
que les banques centrales soit aussi
hostile je trouve qu'elles sont trop
clément de vis à vis du bitcoin mais je
crois qu'elles ont vis-à-vis des
monnaies locales une position qui est
assez saine pour celles que je connais
clie de regarder si ça marche
messi lui on est ce lui au 16e siècle
mais ce n'est qu'il fallait détruire les
régions pour créer l'état aujourd'hui on
n'en est pas là mais alors justement
qu'est-ce que ça pour apporter aux pme
françaises à si la suisse qui pour le
coup elle est née un symbole de
l'institution bancaire
si elle promeut ce genre de système avec
les pme sont aussi nombreuses à le
suivre qu'est ce que ça pourrait
apporter aux pme françaises
si les bêtes si les banques oui je n'ai
jamais donné j'étais la caméra 6 gg non
mais ce n'est même pas un lapsus c'était
une inversion si les banques sont aussi
bête qu'elles veulent bien l'être
aujourd'hui il ya un grand avenir pour
les monnaies locales parce que alors
comment on passe de les changes
monétaires
parce que ce que vous évoquez c'est
quand même principalement des
consommateurs des citoyens qui vont chez
le commerçant la partie entreprise est
généralement relativement marginale mais
ça n'exclut pas que si les banques
continuent à être aussi bête
quelle leçon se développe la partie de
financement des entreprises par des
monnaies locales pourquoi pas ça existe
déjà
alors il ya le vire en suisse mais il ya
aussi un modèle qu'on a visités lors de
cette mission gouvernementale qui est en
sardaigne
sarr d'aix et c'est plusieurs milliers
de pme et pas que des petites qui
fonctionne sur un système de chambres de
compensation en sardaigne et qui a mis
en place un système qui a aujourd'hui
pignon sur rue dans le développement
économique de la sardaigne
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui les millions
d'euros échangés par ce hard ex sur le
marché ce hard ex quelque part et donc
de la sardaigne
alors on peut retrouver la côte et
identitaire là pour le coup on a une
région très forte sur le plan de
l'échangé inter entreprises fonctionnent
au delà des échanges entre petits
commerçants et petits artisans
car qu'on est on voit que sur certaines
régions d'europe il ya un développement
vers des tailles d'entreprises plus
importante et mon avis et passe à la
limite
la limite c'est l'éco système qui
fonctionne et ce hard ex a mis en place
un écosystème avec des outils avec de
l'investissement et je pense qu'on a là
un enjeu sur l'inter entreprises parce
que je finis juste là dessus en france
60% aujourd'hui des dépôts de bilan
notamment des petites et moyennes
entreprises cédées défaut de financement
et pas des défauts d'activité donc on a
un vrai problème sur les écarts de
trésorerie sur la gestion de la
trésorerie
c'est pas moi qui ai lu sortie c'est une
marque les 10 les délais de paiement
sont très longs donc l'espagne et du
coup ça va les attirer et sa valise les
dirai pas parce qu'ils sont fascinés par
le développement durable ou par
l'écologie parce que la plupart des
entreprises n'ont pas mis sa à l'ordre
du jour de leur agenda à court terme
mais parce que de façon très pragmatique
elle se disent aujourd'hui pour gérer
mais ce délai de trésorerie mais écart
de 13
ou avoir un prêt les banques ne sont
plus des interlocuteurs pour moi parce
que je suis une petite ou moyenne
entreprise et qu'elle ne me prêtent plus
d'argent et qu'elle mette plus des
conditions nécessaires pour que je
maintienne mon activité et donc à partir
de là elles se disent un système de
chambres de compensation comme ça ça
fonctionne j'y vais à fond et ça marche
la mise en scène sa marche annuelle mais
je conteste complètement les chiffres
que vous avez que vous avez cités cepal
c'est pas la réalité
si on prend l'ensemble des dépôts de
bilan ses parents a nommé d'accord mais
il des études y en a énormément et la
majorité concluent que le la mais
l'écrasante majorité des dépôts de bilan
c des fautes de gestion la partie
inaccessibilité du crédit étant
relativement marges ils ont tant pis on
les remet ça trottait après vous avez
dit un deux trois mots qui sont
essentiels ces chambres de compensation
c'est qu'à un moment pour que ça se
développe il faut recentraliser même
s'il est au niveau local et plus ça sera
centralisé d'où ma remarque tout à
l'heure par rapport aux marchés dérivés
qui sont pas centralisées plus à
centraliser plus les monnaies locales
pourront se développer y compris avec et
la population des banques centrales
comme si nous arrivons au terme de ce
débat une race 30 secondes juste pour
terminer et ce qu'en cas de grave crise
monétaire
les monnaies les monnaies locales
peuvent jouer leur rôle oui oui elles
peuvent jouer un rôle d'amortisseur de
la crise n'a le joue déjà
pour moi le joue déjà très bien mais
alors c'est sûr ces derniers mots qu'on
terminera ce débat merci à tous d'être
venus sur ce plateau c'était le dernier
docu débat de la saison j'en profite
pour remercier les équipes de public
sénat qui nous ont aidés avec laurent
bazin a préparé cette émission tout au
long de l'année
merci à vous d'être félicités que
féliciter votre fidélité et à bientôt